asteroiden einschlag in europa das ist
das übungsszenario von esa nasa während
ihrer frühjahrs übung das risiko eines
asteroiden einschlag ist der real
deswegen muss geübt werden was wäre also
wenn ein asteroid im april entdeckt
würde der auf kollisionskurs mit der
erde ist und nur ein halbes jahr später
mit voller wucht mitten in europa
einschlagen würde
das ergebnis der übung ist dann disaster
klicks um die user hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen immer wieder
entdecken astronomie teams weltweit
asteroiden die die erde nur knapp
verfehlen die nasa beispielsweise hat
viele hast du ihnen im visier und
informiert auf einer internetseite
täglich über den aktuellen stand der
asteroiden vorhersage die gute nachricht
demnach muss wahrscheinlich in der
nächsten zeit erst mal kein verheerender
asteroideneinschlag auf der erde
befürchtet werden doch wie groß die
gefahr wirklich ist kann niemand mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit sagen der
lediglich 95 prozent der erdnahe
asteroiden die mehr als einen kilometer
groß sind werden von fachleuten weltweit
überwacht bei den brocken die nur
minimal kleiner sind ist die
dunkelziffer zudem sehr hoch und so
werden manche hast du jeden erst kurz
vor ihrem nahen vorbeiflug entdeckt dazu
hieß es von der nasa im sommer das wie
zitat nur etwa ein drittel der
population von asteroiden gefunden haben
die da draußen sind und eine einschlags
gefahr für die erde darstellen könnten
wir sind also alles andere als gut
vorbereitet dabei geht es ja um leben
und tod dazu kommt wir haben kaum eine
chance zu reagieren selbst wenn wir
wüssten dass ein ernstfall droht wenn
trotz intensiver forschung gibt es
bislang noch keine technologie mit der
wir menschen in der lage wären einen
asteroiden aus seiner bahn zu lenken und
somit das schreckenszenario zu
verhindern für das kommende jahr 2022
ist dafür der erste test angepeilt an
ablenkungsmanöver als eine echte
premiere wir hatten ja hier bei pixum
sinnflut schon darüber berichtet esa und
nasa plan eine sonde in den mond des
asteroiden die moz ein schlagen zu
lassen und ihm somit abzulenken kann die
konversion also die umlaufbahn von
more fonds verändern der test könnte
final zeigen dass die umlenkung eines
asteroiden mit genügend vorlaufzeit
machbar ist auch wenn dieser konkrete
asteroid keine bedrohung für die erde
darstellt doch wie könnten unsere
möglichkeiten auf der erde aussehen wenn
ein asteroid entdeckt wird die sich auf
kollisionskurs mit der erde befindet
genau das haben wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler der nasa und esa in
diesen wochen geübt wie können und
müssen wir also bei einem solchen
katastrophen szenario reagieren und
kommuniziert wer sind die
schlüsselakteure und gibt es überhaupt
hoffnung für das leben auf der erde bei
einer solchen potenziellen
anschlagsgefahr
klar ist dass die erde im laufe ihrer
geschichte schon einige asteroiden ein
schläge hinter sich hat der hast du idee
vor 65 millionen jahren einschlug und
die dinosaurier auslöste war etwa zehn
kilometer breit mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 65.000 kilometer pro
stunde war 2013 in der mitte uhr will
haben durchmesser von etwa 30 metern
unterwegs ohne vorwarnung explodiert der
über dem russischen tscheljabinsk vor
zwei jahren war es 130 meter breite
asteroid der sich auf eine entfernung
von nur 72 tausend kilometern der erde
näherte auch hier war die nasa nicht
vorgewarnt der soeben 998 euro 2 hatte
uns im frühjahr des vergangenen jahres
passiert seine größe wurde auf zwei bis
vier kilometer geschätzt
und er hätte die erde mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 60.000 kilometern
pro stunde treffen können 15 mal
schneller also als eine gewehrkugel und
die folgen eines solchen anschlags mal
zu verdeutlichen der ist seit 1998 uhr
zwei hätte wohl locker einen einen
kilometer großen krater auf der erde
verursacht eine stadt wie berlin wäre
somit vollständig ausgelöscht worden
doch nicht nur das asche und staub
hätten enormen einfluss auf das globale
klima und so könnten hungersnöte drohen
auf der ganzen welt forschungsteams
weltweit haben die gefahr kant und
arbeiten mit hochdruck daran gefährliche
asteroiden aufzuspüren zudem werden auch
verschiedene möglichkeiten getestet wie
man einen heranrasenden asteroiden
stoppen könnte
was aber ist in solch einer situation
auf der erde zu tun genau diese frage
wird in diesen wochen von fachleuten
weltweit mit hilfe eines planspiels
beantwortet in diesem szenario wird der
fiktive assoziiert am 19 april entdeckt
toll am 20 oktober desselben jahres
würde er die erde treffen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus europa und den usa
haben die aufgabe einer abwehr mission
zu planen zudem sollten sie auch die
flugbahn des asteroiden und seine
einschlagstelle eingrenzen
weltraumagenturen und der
katastrophenschutz sollen mit solchen
planspielen für den ernstfall hier geht
es schließlich um leben und tod
vorbereitet werden der steckbrief dieses
fiktiven hast du ihn 56 millionen
kilometer entfernt und er könnte
innerhalb von wenigen monaten auf die
erde crash im täglich bekamen die
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer der
simulation weitere informationen zu
seiner größe seiner flugbahn und auch
über die wahrscheinlichkeit eines
einschlags dieses effekts bildeten dann
die basis auf der maßnahmen geplant
werden konnten die fachleute nahmen
dabei verschiedene rollen ein
beispielsweise astronomen astronomen
regierungs vertreterinnen und vertreter
und leute des katastrophenschutzes dazu
lindley johnson von der nasa jedes mal
wenn wir an einer solchen übung
teilnehmen lernen wir mehr darüber
während die schlüsselakteure bei einem
solchen katastrophenfall sind und wer
welche informationen wann benötigt diese
planspiele helfen den akteuren im
bereich der planetaren abwehr die
kommunikation miteinander und mit den
regierungen zu optimieren und
sicherzustellen dass wir im fall einer
potenziellen anschlagsgefahr koordiniert
reagieren in den ersten tagen war die
informationslage zu dem asteroiden der
auf den namen 2021 pdc getauft wurde
noch sehr spärlich die fachleute mussten
also auf der grundlage von wenigen daten
und großen unsicherheiten wichtige
entscheidungen treffen und entsprechende
maßnahmen plant und anleihen dabei war
zu anfang nicht einmal klar ob der erst
wenn tatsächlich die erde treffen wird
eine der großen fragen an dieser stelle
wo genau würde der fiktiver swingt
aufschlagen im planspiel erstreckte sich
die risikozonen am anfang noch über eine
ganze erdhalbkugel
sie reichte von afrika und europa über
den atlantik hinweg bis nach nord- und
südamerika sicher verschont blieben den
ersten informationen zufolge nur der
größte teil asiens und australien
wie stark sich die mögliche ziel zu
nehmen laufe des planspiels eingrenzen
lässt wussten die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer der simulation zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch nicht im weiteren verlauf
des planspiels wurde dann aber klar
dass sich die einsatzzone wohl in
tschechien befinden wird ganz in der
nähe der deutschen und österreichischen
grenze die wurden bei seinem anschlag
wäre gleichzusetzen mit der kraft einer
atombombe die verwüstung einer ganzen
region mit vielen toten und
schwerwiegenden schäden wäre wohl die
folge
und das in einem umkreis von bis zu 200
kilometern um den anschlagsort entfernt
und das was die übung als reaktion zu
bieten hatte war ein desaster die
forschenden der esa und nasa mussten
feststellen dass keine derzeit
verfügbare technologie in der lage wäre
die laufbahn des asteroiden zu verändern
auch eine raumfahrt missionen um den
crash abzuwenden könnte in der kürze der
zeit bis zum einschlag nicht auf die
beine gestellt werden die einzige
möglichkeit um menschenleben zu retten
eine weiträumige evakuierung der
ermittelten einschlags zone auf der esa
webseite ist es folgendermaßen zusammen
gefasst wir können nicht verhindern was
wir nicht vorhersagen können doch klar
ist früher oder später wird ein asteroid
auf der erde einschlagen und daher ist
es wichtig darauf vorbereitet zu sein
dazu detlef koschny von der esa eine
wichtige lehre war dass wir langfristig
planen müssen wie wir potenziell
gefährliche asteroiden erkennen
verfolgen und letztendlich abschwächen
können nur in jährlichen oder zwei
jährlichen planungszielen zu denken wie
viele budgets der öffentlichen
institutionen festgelegt sind ist nicht
genug um einem risiko zu begegnen das
seit hunderten von millionen jahren
besteht
hast du ihn schreibt an erde vorbei so
knapp war es noch nie es passiert
nämlich öfter als viele denken also das
video hier anklicken anschauen und
diesen kanal klickst und science and
future auf jeden fall abonnieren bleibt
dran